hi reject nation I'm Greg Alba what is
your name Courtney right Courtney right
friend of the people of Los Angeles more
than just me and my brother job cat
Courtney have you seen the movie
Avengers infinity horse about time yet
finally caught you so there's this
channel I don't know if you've heard of
him or the crew I don't know I mean they
do awesome it's called mighty raccoon
have you ever heard of mighty raccoon no
the raccoons simple yet they do these
those like fan types of computer
animated short you'll see let's just
watch this war let's watch it 25 million
views damn dude that's a lot of views
Wow back to a few of my raccoons videos
versus Thanos fight scene Wakanda battle
alternate ending
[Applause]
Hey
Oh
that's terrifying
I mean I think I like broken and
battered
oh my gosh this is like violent it
survived Hulk smash oh and Thor's like
why didn't you do that before man Oh No
well they have the glove just snap it in
reverse
jeez there's rocket
Wow body bottle
Wow
[Music]
that's a brutal open yeah I mean I was
not expecting that I was kind of worried
there for a second that it was gonna get
like even more bloody yes yes so much
man I wonder how this is a fun little
fan film you know the effect on the
Hulk's design they look like kind of
have like stubble like a little bit of
hair like he's been through some stuff
when he when you forget that first clear
shot or like base on her it was scary
I wasn't I was genuinely like whoa I've
never been so scared of the okhla floor
till this very moment it was like the
whole planet Hulk if this had happened
in the movie not this exact version but
some resemblance we got more Hulk or
like if the Hulk did come in and beat
Thanos hey it would have made the
cliffhanger or not is because you just
be like grab grab the glove Kourtney's
allergic to cats
so there's a cat that passed beneath her
so anytime that happens that's not me
doing anything appropriate with my hands
remember that hold the bar go let me see
if I could pull it up I think the Russo
brothers I did talk about it because
remember in the beginning of the movie
called commerce yeah fana Hulk lost and
then he was a little baby for them be
that emotional so shortly into an
infinity war Thanos gets into a tussle
with a strongest Avenger the Hulk gets a
few good hits in but ultimately he is no
man okay here's what jonah therisa said
i wouldn't say that he's just powerful
in terms of how like fan o's beat him
you didn't see him actively use the
power stone in that fight I think
ultimately the way we look at that fight
in the way talked about it with our
stunt team when we were executing it was
Hulk is obviously very powerful but he's
a little mindless and
fighting style its aggressive its
pummeling like we saw here that us is
the Genghis Khan the universe he's a
very skilled fighter equally as strong
so you put those two up against each
other the more skilled fighters going to
win which is why Hulk has him overpower
Stannis but ultimately that is smart Oh
interesting I actually didn't really
read that before he's saying that that
Thanos won because he's Morse is smarter
and a more skilled fighter did it really
come across like that to me in the movie
just kind of sound like he was lost
stronger than Hulk yeah it did but then
that second that other paragraph I was
gonna ask you about that one underneath
it the prevailing fan theory there's a
pervading fan theater that Bruce Banner
is actually Loki and his guys I don't
believe that for one second I mean it's
stupid
yeah what do you believe that I don't
believe I'd never had never heard it
before I've heard the one about like
they think that Loki isn't dead because
of his knife is in the wrong hand his
knife is in the left hand and usually
like when he fakes his own death and
Thor the dark world yeah that his knife
was in the left hand and that usually
he's right-handed but you can't grab the
hologram Loki's I'm not saying I'm just
like I just think there it's interesting
you know I agree it's interesting but
they grabbed him in hologram Loki you
know I think we're reaching Loki's gone
over the tires they go way back in time
that would make sense because you could
bring Asgard back I remember you told me
about that
I remember that let's get back on topic
you okay sorry sorry sorry we got we
fell off the path
that's interesting to hear about the
fight because I didn't really
communicate to me there I think this
would have ultimately been disappointing
though cuz if Thanos was just getting
his ass but then again he did have an
axe the Stormbreaker inside of him so I
feel like Hulk could have won in that
moment yeah also cold case show what he
would have been injured yeah okay it's
true because I was wondering I forgot
about that because in this
I didn't notice that there was like a
gash like a wound near his chest like
nearest yeah that's absolutely possible
right see see he could have won he could
have won he could have all right I'm
glad we broke it down cord before we
wrap this video up I want to give a
patron in the day shout to someone now
usually I like to select someone who I
can perfectly suit in a good transition
for a shout out for the video we reacted
to today's Scoob Steve cuz Courtney saw
his name and said I like his name so
we're gonna shout you out scuba you know
Scuba Steve he actually has this really
awesome insert he does graffiti art oh
cool yeah so he lives in the East Coast
think New York and then he does like a
bunch of crazy ass graffiti art which is
totally illegal but he posted all over
Instagram and also I think on our very
last livestream he contributed to the
super chat so not only has he been a
loyal ass patronage act but he's even
contributing more money to the real
rejects in any way he can I like to
think of us as a charity the real
rejects you know you're helping to keep
a channel live I mean yeah you can like
deal with you know charities that are
about like homeless people or people
with diseases or third-world countries
but really the charity you want to give
to is the real chicks and that's a
school Steve does for us yes I hope that
you give to all the charities on YouTube
all the different patreon because
support your favorite creators are you
know this is hard and subscribe to
mighty raccoon subscribe to the real
rejects thanks for making your garden
check her out on Instagram Twitter
and patreon exists bye-bye